and it translated there's no god but
Allah Muhammad is His Messenger I was
like oh is that what they say before
they blow up women dusters I just my
finger cuz I don't know any better
so I just google it like like okay like
what do they say when
flighty to high level vada pav
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends we are in California yes we are
today I've got special video for you
guys I met a brother called Jose he's a
Mexican Bravo
who's come to Islam his story is
touching he doesn't give me the full
story but even from the beginning it's a
beautiful story he's also a security
guard quite dangerous weather pissed oh
we're gonna go find out what's going on
he's right next to his cop car I'm gonna
be hit in there you can follow me from
here in the car or up there you'll find
out what I'm talking about so guys I
might take the public transport no I'm
not I'm going with this yes this place
so we're going to brother Jose oh he's
right at that corner insha'Allah and
we're going to talk to him he seems like
a very very good proper of mashallah and
may Allah bless him comes from a Mexican
background I'm actually I think the
first Mexicans have ever come across so
we're gonna find out exactly how he came
to estimate here we are
he's waiting for us
okay guys the hose eels on their own
zero we're gonna find I was gonna tell
me how to pronounce that right here
right next was police car hopefully no
bullets will be fired
we're gonna find that in Shiloh follow
what's inside the car
okay it's gonna be hot in this car first
time I'm in an American police car oh
yeah yes so brother luckily it's not the
back yeah
are you comfortable it might be a long
talk okay so so me come firstly I love
listen shut up for your time
how do you pronounce your name oh I said
hold Hosea
it's a Jose Palacios Jose yeah okay but
your Muslim name is Yousef okay same
thing okay can you explain that to us he
also broke my sister's he said to me
Jose cuz I suppose I Joseph yeah so what
was it is that like a mexican accent
yeah so Jose is Joseph in Spanish yeah
and isn't it Joseph is also Youssef so
okay yeah so instead of just instead of
translating Youssef to Joseph you just
translate Youssef to Jose okay sure
that's an interesting fact
so now obviously I know an old river
stories and stuff like that are done in
a moocher sitting inside for to make a
before add a bit of spice into it yeah
and so I could tell me your story yeah
okay
before Islam what was you doing how did
it all happen you gave me a little
breathing story but tell me
firstly what you was doing before stop
okay what was your first occurrence with
a Muslim and the first occurrence with
Islam
you think we have a couple hours on
there so before before I was Muslim I
grew up in a diverse neighborhood I grew
up in San Jose California yeah mostly
Hispanics there of course didn't really
come across too many other parent
besides a few white people and like
black people but you know I'm done I
like my family was never war was always
been kind people never grew up with any
prejudice against anyone so whenever I
saw people of any other like culture or
anything I never thought like oh look at
them like why are they wrapped up all
right this way I just saw them as it as
another human being basically yeah so we
moved over here when I was younger and I
knew a couple of Muslim people in high
school but I just I never classified
anyone that got something or just my
friends who just happen to be Arab or
middle-eastern and I know I was close to
them you know I played football they
were on the football team as well you
were very close and sorry those people
coming in and out
yeah but they weren't practicing so I
didn't learn anything about Islam or
anything like that from them it was
through my own their own research and
studies that I found it but so leaning
on you know I was life progressed on you
know b-before days of Julia's some
people say yeah
I was kind of just going life you know
one day at a time yeah so I was just
focusing on work and school I had I grew
up with religiously Catholic so a lot of
Hispanics Mexicans are so their families
scuffle yeah yeah like Roman Catholic
some of them will be Christian but the
other day it's kind of was the same
thing yeah but ever since I was little I
always had my doubts my questions like
okay why are we doing this why we're
doing that does it make sense you know
while you're praying to Jesus if he's
the son of God and we pray to God you
say there was an instance in your house
where they'll you say there was a
picture of Mary the mother of Jesus or
something like that
yeah yeah so I was saying like walking
she's covered up other people are
supposed to cover up like oh it's just
back then and you know I had questions -
I was like I was like we know why is she
why is she lightly skin complected like
if she's from the Middle East
she should be like dark you know Jesus
blonde up exactly yeah just substances
that so it's not that I didn't believe
in God I just became more agnostic took
it as a higher being mmm I feel I just
wasn't sure what the right path was okay
so some of the brothers said that they
knew you before you used to work someone
yes I used to work at the grocery store
over a Save Mart we have over here yeah
yes I'll just work at the cashier or
work stalking the aisles and
so I guess I also had Muslim friends
that have known growing up here yeah so
they taught me a few phrases like
assalamu alaikum okay so whenever I saw
like a Muslim person yeah it was mostly
the women because obviously I can tell
whenever I walk or cycle and they get
Psychlo alaikum salam' and they talk
everybody at so that was just that I
would see them every now and then say
something like them I would kind of like
go on my way just to just to go say hi
to them because I mean myself pursue the
way I am I got like communicating with
people I like making people feel good
about themselves but I don't do Darwin's
love them down
cuz like when I see like you know cuz
our job is like then go so who say hi to
every customers but I noticed some other
co-workers when they saw them they're
kind of little hesitant to go I was like
you know I'm not afraid I'll go say hi
to them so that was it okay and what was
your first occurrence with Islam that
was a Muslim and he said Salaam okay how
did you get to find out about it's now
so it's just a couple of different
instances where I would do yeah I would
study once one topic or occurrence that
came up so this might sound a little
like awkward or a bad point of view to
get it from by Lee I like watching like
war movies and stuff okay I see like
Black Hawk Down Oh things like that yeah
so I'm Black Hawk Down they would have
transition scenes to where they would
play the call to prayer between scenes
mmm whenever I write here I was like now
like I don't know what this is but it
sounds nice I wish they played that here
because I felt like well maybe maybe one
of the points of the video is to vilify
certain group of people but look how in
return does caused you to you then what
then weapon yes so then and then another
time to like so the same instance they
because you know how there's YouTube
videos that are shared like on Facebook
and it's I believe it was like during
Ramadan it was like that I wear
and they were there all praying and that
they had the English translations yeah
and then so the user who posted it was
saying look at these Muslims look how
they're talking about like killing us or
someone in the prayer but I'm saying
that I'm actually I'm actually taking
the time to actually read the actual
subtitles I'm like what are you talking
about this is nice like I think it
sounds beautiful like I wish I was yeah
but just stuff I thought you know I
never you know I never went in with any
prejudice against like okay so you said
did you say you such that any specific I
don't know comment but you say you
searched it's something in Google and if
you heard something from the other no am
I mistaken so just different things like
that woke up like what is the noise like
just a what is that noise that comes I
would say noise and then I got another
movie called the kingdom yeah where the
guy blows himself up but before he he
does it yes he says the Shahada and is
before I knew was to shout that but you
know how to put the subtitles on in the
movie and it translated there's no god
but Allah Muhammad is the messenger I
was like oh is that what they say before
they blow up in Dustin's house just my
thinking cuz I don't know any better
so I just google it like like oh okay
like what do they say when they for they
blow up like and then stuff came up and
then that guy started like oh that's not
what it's supposed to be used for but
then there's learning as yeah I know
but as I kept going like finding more
stuff obviously like you know yeah
YouTube related videos three hours later
you're something else
yeah I just I started watching all these
videos that came across like I did that
and all that and then I was like and
then also on holiday I seen yeah yeah
all those and then from there I was just
like wow like there's a lot more
similarities than I thought that there
would be at all yeah and then as I
started watching more and more videos
and doing my own research I was like you
know this this makes more logical sense
since this answers the questions that
that I've had when I look at these I see
no like contradictions or anything and I
feel like this is something for me this
is what I've been looking for because
before then in my life everyone no
matter where you come from you you have
your ups and downs you that's your
similar things like I had a lot of
course close friends at a young age dial
on different answers incidences like
either a drunk driving accident or you
got hit by a car just some freak
accident you know so like my aunts and
uncles that's the fact that you know it
makes when things like that happen you
really start to wonder like what's gonna
what's after this yeah you know what's
what's to come and I really started
getting concerned about like that's
interesting mildly similar stories will
add a lot people without you know what
commit suicide possibly and you need to
change okay so then what happened
because it was a one of the brothers
said that they said that you want to
take a shot or something like that
O'Connor would you when did you realize
and say look this is the truth
I wanna accept this down or you know and
there's an amazing story coming up it's
gonna come up but yeah so um it's like I
said I found out all these things like I
was amazed by it like I was so
infatuated with you know culture yeah
but it never dawned upon me like like
like to become Muslim cuz for me like I
don't know why in my head I was like oh
like this is for them oh they're so
luckily they have this I wish I was that
but um so I was still over at savemart
and then one of the brothers here I'm
not
Marshall his family may Allah continue
to bless them they were they were coming
through the checkout stand again and
then same thing yeah so I wanna come are
you guys today and I wake up soon are
you Muslim and I was like oh no like why
not like oh I don't know and then like
oh why don't you come over with it just
around the corner mmm so what time you
off I'm like I'm off in an hour like oh
please please come over yeah and I was
like like okay like man these people are
so welcoming like of course
except they're invite so you know before
I'm when I got off I was like oh man
what do these people like like to eat so
I mean I go I go over to the deli
section I'm like let me get a plate of
hummus some bread side take it over to
them yeah so I go over there and then so
they sit down with me and they just
start you know asking me questions okay
like what do you know like do you have
any questions and they go like like what
brought you here and I'm telling him all
these things and they're like wow you
know so much like how come you don't
become Muslim I was like why don't you
come like come take to Java
I was like you people usually do it like
on Fridays rent when there's more people
there and it was a Monday and I was like
I was like I don't I don't care - like
wait for Friday if I believe now I'm
gonna do it now so we went we went that
night
yeah you know special prayer and then we
came here I prayed
and I took the shadow that's amazing man
it just shows you you know something
that already they just need a little
push yeah that's amazing man and so
what's more beautiful my shows that like
the brothers would say that you would
travel 40 minutes on your skateboard oh
yeah yeah so uh by that time my car had
broken down hmm and so I would like bike
to work yeah and
bike escape or whatever I can at the
time mm-hmm and then we had moved
because before you slip over by st. mark
and then we moved about a few miles by
car yeah and so this is when you first
start you're on that hype you you want
to keep researching and studying yeah so
I would be up watching you know I'm
indeed that videos and all that the
merciful servant yeah like Islamic
guidance and all that on YouTube and so
like 3:00 a.m. I'm like okay if legends
and an hour and a half and I leave now I
can make it
so I'll start walking and I'll start
walking I'm listening Quran all right
then I'm singing out loud oh my god why
I'm walking and a shawl I'll get there
like in an hour or so
hmm and then sometimes I would walk in
and as soon as I'm walking onto the onto
the property they're leaving on my god
I'd have to turn around yeah that's
crazy that's crazy man what advice would
you give to people out there who are
maybe right now Washington they're in
the same state as you are and the only
two months about accepting Islam or
taking a shot
first and foremost don't be afraid to
just go talk to Muslims you know if you
have if you have any friends or if
there's an Islamic Center near you
most of the time you know you're more
than welcome
yeah anywhere they're always willing to
accept people to come and ask questions
you might have been mashaallah
cuz I don't to see if it wasn't for that
family I probably would have never
that's what that was so keep on sisters
what's one thing that you love Iceland
that want to let you know so one thing I
would like is cuz before and my
Catholicism we would have to go to the
church right and you would have to
confess to the priest like the little
boxes I like how there's no middleman
like you don't have to tell anyone your
businesses between you and your Lord and
you can like you can be like anywhere
alright and like especially what the
lecture exactly remember that if you
think it okay I need to go to this
specific place to repent do you get it
and a lot you can do it anywhere did you
get it and you know Allah sponsor says
that if mankind was not to sin I will
destroy them and bring far for another
nation it would sin but repent desert
yeah and what that shows is it shows our
last scene we're gonna sin but
acknowledge this is very important as a
matter of tawheed akan religion I have a
Lord
that's all forgiven most merciful that's
a that's a form of tawheed that's
worship now you're in you know but
that's why she talked on this is all
you're a sinner you're gonna go and do
this is it wants to put you off of
repenting and repenting that's not for
everyone you know it's it's not for
everyone it's something that Allah gives
to
does anything else when I've done oh so
the same thing like for so for me you
know I grew up in a little rougher
neighborhood yes I'm sorry
so some people not all reverts officer
we come from different backgrounds so of
course there's things that sometimes
people might do to where like they
regret right they feel like for me like
I didn't for me I almost felt like oh
for sure I'm going to have like theirs
I've done so many things I've done this
and that yeah and there's times were
some things that I've done alright and
then I just sit there contemplating like
like man like there's there's no hope
for my really felt hopeless because it
was a whole bunch of things like mmm
probably even like the year before I
became a son yeah it's like I said one
of my close on calls had passed away
yeah and then one of my ex-girlfriends
who I was with for a while like we had
broken up so I was just on a downhill
downhill slope you know I was getting
really depressed you know I was out
there drinking party I was trying to
fill this void ya know I could fill it
up that it be temporary you know how to
fill it up for the night out at the out
to clubs or anything but then in the
morning it's back it's even worse now I
have now I'm depressed and I have a
headache
yeah I didn't yeah exactly you know he
was and then now like I have I have so
much more to be grateful for so now like
with some the teachings like it's almost
it's hard to get depressed mmm because
like if something happens in my life it
could be worse go get those who are
below this was a beautiful story
mushroomy our best in each other we're
in a beautiful state California and for
more to come up call me a lock on a
Sepulchre Salaam California T Mia till
next time subscribe share like share
with your friends and family assalamu
alaikum wa rahmatu a better case for me
and LAPD
what imagine the city PowerShell
Oh
ready to finally move in the power
what then
be kidding